pain lately i've become very well
acquainted with it
the type that comes when you've been
hurt repeatedly by the same person
you've been gushing about seattle since
the day i first met you
if he loves you he could follow you
i was hoping that we would move to
london after graduation
and how was i supposed to know that
[Music]
only in those rare moments when he pulls
me to his chest
and makes promises he never seems able
to keep
does the pain disappear
[Music]
relationships they're complicated
you have a great job in seattle but i
don't have anything there
you'd have me okay that's not enough if
i'm not enough
that's your problem but you're not gonna
stop me
i won't give up seattle for you so you
just turn on me
[Music]
this is what you do you sabotage every
good moment that we have
no no if i wanted to try and sabotage a
good moment i would have brought another
guy's number in your dress you don't get
to choose who i have his friends
they don't want to be your friends okay
[Music]
i can't tell what's true and what's not
[Music]
you're my better place
[Music]
you